i've seen him go through a lot i always
know his heart
kim kardashian breaks her silence
following kanye west's comments over the
weekend at his presidential rally
and on twitter the 39-year-old reality
star is asking for compassion
and empathy from the public he's just
the most
genuine person and you know he might say
things that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it
on wednesday the reality star took to
her insta story
posting a lengthy message about her
husband and his battle with bipolar
disorder
kim explained that she has never spoken
publicly about how it has affected their
family
because she is protective of kanye and
their children's privacy
but added that she is commenting on it
now because of the stigma and
misconceptions
about mental health kim defended kanye
calling him brilliant but
complicated and added quote living with
bipolar disorder does not diminish or
invalidate his dreams and his creative
ideas no matter how big or unattainable
they may feel to some
that is part of his genius the skim's
designer thanked fans for their concern
and understanding and asks that people
show kanye and others struggling with
mental health
grace i called my wife
and she said we're gonna have this baby
kim's message comes after kanye's
emotional speech during his presidential
campaign rally in south carolina over
the weekend
where he said he considered an abortion
when kim was pregnant
with their first child north even if my
wife were to divorce me
after this speech she brought north into
the world
even when i didn't want to she stood up
and she protected that child
on monday kanye launched into a string
of since-deleted tweets
claiming his wife and her mom kris
jenner were trying to lock him
up and on tuesday in another now deleted
tweet
kanye claimed he's been considering a
divorce
for years but when it comes to kim a
source tells et
that she's standing by her man's side
and is not planning to divorce
kanye the source also recalled that
kanye was by kim's side after she was
robbed at gunpoint
in paris back in 2016. he dropped
everything to be right by her side
that's the guy kanye is and that's the
guy kim loves
kim is there for kanye and although
right now he doesn't want her by his
side
she's ready to drop everything for him
when he's ready
for now a source tells e.t that the kkw
beauty designer
is staying strong for their four
children quote
kim is taking this time to make sure her
children are happy and not involved in
anything that's going on kim is
surrounded by her family
and they've been strong for her
you